nella gt ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi dio sono spa vi j
e questo è un virus come far girare le
eliche del caffè l'avvocato email perché
oggi faremo una cosa che non abbiamo mai
fatto ovvero una sfida davvero non ha
scritto la chan la scatola già e la
scheda gialla contiene le armi della
sfida azzurri
allora ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
challenge
il fatto è che stefano sta tentando in
altri non lo sciopero alla bisogna
preparare del latte this week
freddo e bisogna farlo senza giudizio
delle mani mentre 400 ml di latte nella
caraffa avete una linea 6 per gli
stupidi non riescono a calcolare poi
dobbiamo inserire 4 cucchiai di nesquik
girare dai 35 ai bisogna versare il
contenuto all'interno del sestiere che è
una porzione c'è una possesso di qui
perché chi perché può essere fatto
l'arte freddo milionario
anche la brillante così idea l'ha fatto
fatto fatto tanto ma io sono ancora
all'inizio andate piano tecnico è tutta
aperta
va bene anche discusso nostre ragazze
arrivate insieme alla seconda parte
della challenge è la prima si è conclusa
io sono arrivato primo
io credo per me chi ha piu bicchieri ha
perso io figlio prima tesi come sono
arrivato ultimo io c'ho più bicchieri
che abbiamo versato al latte freddo
nesquik il contenuto appunto del sale
in questi allora c'è l'ex consiste nel
non ho mai fatto naturale non ho
comunque cosa ha scritto non ho mai
fatto il bagno dell'arte se tu hai fatto
il bagno nel latte
vai avanti lei quindi bene anche per
vincere devi bere il latte per
acquisirebbe non abbiamo avuto un black
edition parla carlo preso la bancarella
freddo non ho mai preso in mano un ragno
e mappe ma cosa vuol dire più ucciderlo
in mano le tesi e poi la canadese marino
sia stato un lanciafiamme fate voi
la vera mente ci sono aracnofobia cosa
bollirà è bello di euro in sé kg finisce
prima è 7 erano normali come a tre non è
mai fatto l'autostop un'ormai fattoria
perché il mio nome è nessuno che fa
telai maltoni alla bild
trovo questa faccia piega luca persico
capisco io non ho mai scritto una
ragazza che adesso mi piace a dio poste
quando tutti sono scappate sinceramente
ho mai mangiato un insetto io volevamo
una cavalletto li ho dati colombotto e
non
con nick e remo seri non mangia mai
bocciato la teste traver grease ragazzi
hanno saputo lasciata aperta nessuna
ragione ai visitatori
13 azione che è quello che dà di più
nella vita di vera lisa capisca non ho
mai visto che cosa perché è cos'è stato
adesso non ho mai scattato una mia foto
e cosa no spendono 10 punti meno in
bicchieri che abbiamo davanti
erano 300 tipi chiedete ma fate bene
prendere una calcolo se fosse ai cinque
cioccolato un punto mai visto l'alba mai
visto l'arma in spiaggia non l'ho mai
visto qui non bevo uguale va bene ma nei
fatti
noi lavoriamo e vincere allora e quindi
66 punti da ragazzi
allora ragazzi siamo sulla seconda
challenge in realtà ci sono due
bicchieri 1 contiene latte freddo
nesquik el'altro prova basti cosa che
non voglio sapere e prende quello buono
anche faccia la fortuna nell'anima e
quindi prende tre punti il tuo bicchiere
e pd avendo questo io direi questo bravo
padre io io vado sul caso busi è l'amara
di stefano lei cambiata con qualcun
altro non sia in video che ho sentito
nessuno alla fine soffiano ottimo e li
buoni nei telefoni chi vince chi vince
prende tre punti c'è chi beve di vedere
vabbè andiamo noi abbiamo cominciato
davvero i miei suonare fai schifo
irrigazione aveva visti coinvolti due
forni
l'area ma il team e biologia io mi sono
fidato di me 2
siamo a lanciare lancio finale dobbiamo
lanciare questi cubetti di latte prendo
e me script dentro questi bicchieri che
si chiama next week fox ha più tiri chi
ha vinto le altre challenge io che non
ho vinto la mazza ciò tipo un tiro a
giro della speranza se riesci a prendere
quello poi viene anche se lo tutti
centro inizia gli onori nessun ricovero
rete prima della trasmissione vada
lagos correre da 5 paradosso costo di
bravi ad esami invasivi immagini possa
vedersi mappato metà mezzo mi fa bene
visto bicchiere non ci credo ma si
rimane una fase critica una delle sicure
che appare breve morbido ma l'oggetto
fruttare saccoccia al punto aspetta se
va bene portare ho fatto
ma dove va benissimo ma non è il solo
tiro e lui lo prende e porta i calzini
giusto non se lo aspettava e mezzo di
898 appunto il giovane importante
ricordate e non è fatto a venezia una
vigna l'appeal su rai ha perso maschile
dato penitenza consiste nel che non è
così male
di vista devi per rimorchiare cinque
ragazze che hanno almeno 60 anni
la cosa indossi serio la base 60 anni
credo tutto 106 che cosa facciamo 55
ragazze non so come una sfida premi si
capisce prima va bene la sfida
combattere ma ragazzo di paure 25 baci
che ventenne di vista non è così male
bocca al lupo sulle mi disse tavoli
nesquik ciao ragazze mi calcolate un
attimo per favore al ciocco una
bellissima levana di nesquik e latte
freddo
vi giuro che non ci posso credere
pazienti gravi di cui io vesto pazzo ma
dove vai tu perché prendere portare
dalle persone io sono un aggressore
attende da bar siamo qua buona cena un
abbraccio mi sento solo un abbraccio non
ho chiesto chissà cosa e disagio o su
quelle ragazze vabbè c'è una buona
serata
ciao ragazze si mette un po di nesquik
sono gli abbagli per cui non ho paura di
andare dietro siamo il latte fede di
scritte e orali scusa posso secondo
dischi anch'io
grazie soprattuto i premi ghiaccio ecco
però rimaniamo piaciuti che arriva
qualcun altra cui effetto catena è avete
mai baciato un ragazzo possa venire
scritte sono cose da fare nella vita
scusate la maturità
sì però in questi movimenti si prendono
le biglie tra le mani giocatori
aspirazionali ispirazione anche il 9
anni faccio certo sulla guancia ma
possiamo certo funziona così oggi
ragazzi dopo queste figure barbine dire
che lanciamo la sfida finale
se succede lanciamo la sfida finale che
chi riuscirà a preparare nel latte
freddo e nesquik nel modo più creativo
vincerò una giornata o con me o con gli
illuminati qua presenti e qui già
scritto il nome leggi mar alcuni mesi ma
vorrei lanciare punta il sito
descrizione quindi se volete caricare i
vostri video per la sfida di fa tesi
tanto speciale io ringrazio gli studi i
make sperava veste parlano troppo celata
novi